Hello again I am going to answer this question while I retouch my makeup
and I am telling you the truth is that I do not understand very well the
question I thought that in Spain in general people knew 8 surnames of
theirs because it is very simple 8 surnames in ascending order from me to
my parents to my to my you are asking the surnames normally here in Euskal
herría people usually know their surnames then a I was told them when I was
a child I learned them as I say in the video in one shot and I know up to 8
I don't know more than 8 but if you ask your parents or or uncles a family
member surname and you go making 1 family tree of surnames you get up to 8
10 16 25 those that I get to know basically that is it The truth is that
now that I think about it I think that the title of the film of 8 Basque
surnames still has something to do with that because I thought it was
something quite common in all of Spain but it is still something
characteristic of Euskal herría I don't know we should look at it the truth
but in short that's the story it's just IR doing in order up in your family
tree in your family and IR doing 1 list of surnames and until you have all
of them because that's 1 good exercise.
because you still learn things about your family and Tal in the end
surnames have meaning and have history I've been looking for mine
lately and I've freaked out the truth so I hope you found this video
useful as an answer I hope I explained it well and nothing 1 kiss agur.